aujourd'hui c'est le cinquième anniversaire du meurtre de sa
famille
comment va ma fille ma fille a de l'amour dans son
cœur et de la neige dans ses yeux dans son sang
chaque mot qu'ils tuent c'est le nord je suis
vraiment désolé pour votre perte
nous avons trois suspects en détention mais
ils sont tous liés au cartel de Garcia
aucun témoin n'a été disposé à
intensifier ces cartels ce n'est pas une blague ils ont
tout le monde dans leurs poches vous avez
vécu une terrible tragédie peut-être que vous
n'avez pas vu ce que vous pensez avoir vu
avez-vous fait une erreur numéro trois
numéro cinq numéro quatre boulons dans votre
souvenir n'est pas ce que vous pensiez que
c'était les preuves sont insuffisantes pour retenir
les accusés pour le procès vous pensez
que vous allez avoir la justice les faire
tous toute la journée
[Musique]
Il y a cinq ans, Crowley North vient de
disparaître complètement de la grille, alors
elle passe les cinq dernières années à faire
ce qui s'entraîne bien, c'est nouveau,
je pense honnêtement que Riley North a fait cela
aujourd'hui, le cinquième anniversaire du meurtre de sa
famille, elle est b  ack
juges corrompus flics sales eh bien je veux
une fois que c'est ce qui rend cette zone à faible taux de
criminalité c'est une faible criminalité à cause d'elle
de vous, cela vous transforme en
quelqu'un d'autre,
les médias sociaux s'illuminent de soutien pour
elle, elle est une suspecte d'homicide multiple,
pas pour eux, elle n'est pas un
homme et maintenant Dieu
kyuri, les choses vont aller, je vais tuer
chacun d'entre vous à peu
près à partir de là
vous